Speaker 1: The January 6th committee doesn't have
much time left because Republicans are taking
over the House in January. And Republican Adam
Kinzinger now says that Donald Trump absolutely is
guilty of crimes committed in advance of January
6th. There's a report from the Hill. Congressman
Adam Kinzinger, Republican from Illinois, said
Wednesday that former President Trump is, quote,
absolutely guilty of a crime surrounding the
January six riot at the Capitol. I think he's
guilty of a crime. This is a quote. I mean, look,
he knew what he did. We've made that clear. He
knew what was happening prior to January 6th. He
pressured the Justice Department officials to say,
hey, just say the election was stolen and
leave the rest to me. And then the Republicans
all need to put the stamp of approval on it.
Kinzinger told CNN's Jake TAPPER on the lead,
quote, I think he is absolutely guilty if he is
not guilty of some crime, of some kind of a crime.
I mean, what we've basically said is presidents
are above the law and they can do everything short
of a coup as long as it doesn't succeed. Kinzinger
said, though he gave the caveat that even as a
member of the January six panel, he doesn't
have the DOJ's power to press charges. Well,
that we know you could make the case that
over the four years ending on January six,
2021 or January 10th, 2021, Donald Trump
committed dozens of counts of obstruction.
Put that aside from possible sedition based
on his actions. Myriad conspiracy charges of
all kinds associated with the Republican coup
attempt, mishandling of classified documents,
taking classified documents. And then in addition
to that minimum on the criminal side, think about
all of the potential civil claims that could be
made. Reminder that is important, which is if and
until we have reason to revise our belief. It is
pretty widely known that the Department of Justice
to some degree accepts that the president is
above the law, not in a literal sense. But
there is this convention that has taken place. And
until we actually see the DOJ behave differently,
we don't really have a reason to revise that
perspective. So the January six committee will be
meeting next week. They announced that yesterday.
It's a it's described as a business meeting.
Business for them is a little bit different than
what we consider to be business. But presumably,
they will be meeting to make a decision as
to what, if any, criminal referrals they are
going to make. The news from last week, the
January 6th committee will be making criminal
referrals. Will they in there, in fact, do
that and against whom? Remains to be seen.